now i'd like to demonstrate one way to
construct a sine wave what we're going
to do is we're going to construct
something that looks like sine of omega
t so we have our function of time here
and we have our frequency
now this little animation is going to
show us a way to construct a sine wave
so what i have here this green line
is a rotating vector and let's just say
that the the radius of this circle is
one
so here's a vector just rotating slowly
around and around
and in the dotted line here and that
yellow dot going up and down
that's the projection
that's the projection of the tip of the
green arrow onto the y-axis
and as the vector goes round and around
you can see that the the projection on
the y-axis is is bobbing up and down and
up and down and that's actually going up
and down in a sine wave pattern
so now i'm going to switch to a new
animation and we'll see
we'll see what that dot looks like as it
goes up and down in time
so here's the plot here's what a sine
wave looks like as you notice when the
green line goes through zero right there
let's wait till it comes around again
the value of the yellow line when it
goes through zero
is zero
so this yellow line here is a plot of
sine
of omega t
now if i go to a projection this
projection was on to the y axis and i
can do the same animation but this time
project onto the x-axis and that will
produce for us a cosine wave let's see
what that looks like
now in this case if we switched over you
can see that the projection that dotted
green line is on to the x-axis and what
this is doing is it's producing a cosine
wave for us so this is
this is going to be cosine of omega t
now because we're tracking the the
the progress on the x-axis the cosine
wave seems to emerge going down on the
page so the time axis is down here
when the green arrow is zero right there
the value of the cosine was one
and when it's minus 180 degrees it's
minus 1 on the cosine so that's why this
is a cosine wave
and it has the same frequency as the
sine wave we generated
and now i want to show you these two
together because it's just sort of a
beautiful drawing
i'll leave our animation here for a
second we see our sine wave being
generated in yellow and in orange we see
the cosine wave being generated and
they're both coming from this rotating
green vector
so this is a really simple demonstration
of a way to generate sines and cosines
with this rotating vector idea
we're going to be able to generate this
rotating vector using some ideas from
complex arithmetic
and euler's formula
i find these to be a really beautiful
pattern and it emerges from such a
simple idea as a rotating vector